[Musique]
bonjour depuis le 16 juin les députés de
la commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de kobe 19 auditionnent les
acteurs de la crise sanitaire monde
médical mais aussi ancien ministre et
directeur généraux de la santé tout
l'été lcp vous fait revivre ces
auditions aujourd'hui celle de xavier
bertrand ministre de la santé de 2005 à
2007 puis de 2010 à 2012
il s'explique sur l'appauvrissement
progressif des stocks de masques ou les
coudes tout de suite bonjour chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre nous achevons ce
matin l'audition des quatre ministres
qui étaient aux responsabilité avant le
début de la crise sanitaire lié à
l'épidémie de kovy 19
je rappelle monsieur le ministre que
vous avez été en charge de la solidarité
et de la santé de juin 2005 à mars 2007
puis ministre du travail de l'emploi et
de la santé de novembre 2010 à mai 2012
à partir de 2005 plusieurs alertes
notamment un rapport de l'inspection
générale de l'administration s'inquiète
de l'absence de préparation de la france
en cas de pandémie
en réponse vous demander la constitution
d'un stock de masques et par la loi du 5
mars 2007
l'eprus est créé avec pour mission de
gérer la réserve sanitaire les stops
d'état puis vous avez succédé à madame
roselyne bachelot en novembre 2010 après
les mid et l'épidémie de grippe a h1n1
la question se pose alors de la
reconstitution d'un stock d'état adapté
et de sa gestion active saisie de ces
questions le haut conseil de la santé
publique a rendu un avis le 1er juillet
2011 qui a distingué entre deux types de
stocks de produits de santé d'une part
les stocks stratégiques géré par l'état
et d'autre part les moyens d'y tactique
monsieur le ministre vous êtes également
président du conseil régional de la plus
belle région des hauts de france en
cette qualité de manière très objective
vous avez été amené à lancer des
acquisitions de masque pendant la crise
sanitaire nous retire nous reviendrons
certainement cette question et sur
l'organisation de la réponse locale à la
crise avant de commencer cette audition
messieurs je vais vous demander de
prêter serment
en effet l'article 6 de l'ordonance du
17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires impose aux personnes
auditionnées par une commission denquête
de prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité et rien que la vérité
le jeune juan avant de passer la parole
au rapporteur je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur trois points la première
période durant laquelle vous étiez
ministre de la santé de 2005 à 2007 a
été marquée par l'importance accordée à
la prévention sanitaire qui s'est
caractérisée notamment par la mise en
place d'exercices de préparation face au
risque
la tenue dès mardi grippe ainsi que par
la commande d'un nombre de masques
important pensez vous que cette culture
de la prévention face aux crises a perdu
de son importance
comment pourrait-on à l'avenir la
revaloriser le deuxième point au cours
de cette même période de 2005 à 2007
vous avez encouragé la constitution de
capacités de production nationale une
véritable industrie de production de
masques ayant été créé vous avez soutenu
la production dans la région hôte france
en votre qualité de président durant la
crise du coc vide qu'elle serait
aujourd'hui vos recommandations pour
retrouver en france une plus grande
souveraineté en termes de production de
masques et plus généralement de produits
de santé
et troisièmement s'agissant de la
commande et de la livraison de masque
durant la crise
vous avez indiqué avoir rencontré
d'importantes difficultés
vous déclariez par exemple au journal
l'union le 12 juin que ce serait à
refaire je le referai mais différemment
je savais que ce serait difficile mais
pas à ce point pouvez vous présenter
plus précisément les obstacles
rencontrés indics et la manière dont ils
auraient pu selon vous être évité je
suis pas le
premier des ministres de la santé à
avoir compris l'importance des menaces
sanitaires
bernard kouchner début des années 2000
2001 notamment
on est dans la situation justement des
attentats philippe douste blazy
dès 2003 et avec un premier plan en 2005
qui fait suite à un rapport très
important rapport qui fait autorité
qu'il rappe en de didier raoul ce
rapport dit raul de juin 2003 sur le
bioterrorisme qui fait référence
pas seulement sur le plan national mais
aussi sur le plan international qui
donnera justement mieux à ce qu'on
appelait le plan le plan biotox donc on
ne part jamais d'une feuille blanche en
politique et il est vrai que nous sommes
confrontés à une situation assez
particulière
pourquoi parce que vous avez h5n1 h5n1
c'est une grippe aviaire d'un type
nouveau qui se caractérise à partir de
décembre 2003 paraît d'épizootie c'est à
dire qu'il qui touche les animaux en
premier mais qui prend un autre relief à
partir de juillet 2005 parce que l'on
voit qu'il y à une transmission de
l'animal à l'homme et tout le monde à ce
moment précis se dit que si on a le
passage de l'homme à l'homme
là nous sommes partis pour une pandémie
mondiale
avec un taux de létalité qui est l'un
des plus importants jamais connu et
jamais enregistrée on voit bien que dans
certains élevages notamment en asie
qu'il ya eu ce passage de l'animal à
l'homme
la question qui se pose c'est si ça
paraît très grande échelle
comment les différents pays seront
préparés l'om est saisi de cette
question bien évidemment et en voyant
les différents développements
je propose premier ministre et au
président de la république de me rendre
en asie de façon à voir exactement
comment il se prépare
j'aurai l'occasion de me rendre au
vietnam
j'aurai l'occasion de me rendre en chine
la même occasion à l'occasion de ce
déplacement
et là ça permet de voir à la fois
ce qu'est la préparation dans ces pays
et je me rappelle des changes très
directe notamment avec mon homologue
chinois de la santé
il ya deux choses particulières de
choses qui me marque
il me dit tout d'abord que la situation
dans son pays est toujours complexe à
comprendre que dans les grandes villes
il me dit je peux savoir ce qui se passe
dans mes campagnes
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué c'est pas
qu'il est à la tête
nice terre où il ya deux pays mais sur
les situations très différentes il dit
voilà ce que l'on sait dans les villes
mais par ailleurs je peux pas vous dire
précisément jeudi concernant les masques
nous importons des masses que nous
sommes prêts à en importer en cas de
problème il me dit oui mais soyons très
clairs si jamais nous sommes dans une
situation pandémique
en même temps vous et moi les masques on
les gardera pour nous et il ne me fait
pas leurs proches
vous feriez exactement la même chose si
on était confronté à la même situation
j'ai l'occasion également de rencontrer
dans l'est dans les consulats nous
ressortissants qui sont inquiets se dire
si jamais il y un problème comment on
sera rapatrié et l'autre par commencera
protéger et c'est aussi à ce moment
précis en revenant que je proposerai au
président chirac de pouvoir constituer à
la fois des stocks et des stocks de
tamiflu c'était le fameux médicament
avec un autre qui était le relenza
tamiflu fabriqué par le laboratoire
roche le relenza fabriqué par gsk de
façon à pouvoir leur mettre à
disposition et aussi pour pouvoir les
rassurer c'est ce contact avec eux leurs
questions et interrogations des familles
qui me font prendre conscience aussi de
ce phénomène et à mon retour je
rencontre au président chirac pour qu'il
est question de santé était quelque
chose vous le savez bien d'essentiel
quasiment supérieur à tout le reste et
qui me dit en quelque sorte tu as carte
blanche
il faut justement qu'on soit préparer le
mieux possible et donc c'est à partir de
ce moment là certains ici présents s'en
souviennent que nous avons à préparer le
pays en cas d'un risque sanitaire majeur
notamment avec une pandémie que serait
que serait h5n1 sur la question très
précisément justement
la préparation en masque à partir du
moment où nous voyons notre dépendance
par rapport à la production chinoise
asiatiques puisque le vietnam produit
également des masses pc principalement
l'asie
je propose au président de la république
c'est que nous ayons une force de
production nationale et c'est à ce
moment précis que l'on prendra la
décision de faire des commandes très
importantes de masques auprès du sinn
qui seront en france certaines existent
déjà qui vont justement s'adjoindre
cette spécialité
d'autres vont se crée toutes pièces et
elles ont la garantie qu'elles auront en
quelque sorte un marché captif avec la
production nationale avec la production
française avec la production pour
l'ensemble des ministères et c'est comme
ça que l'on a un certain nombre d'unités
qui sont créées vous avez bacou-dalloz
vous avez macopharma deltalyo deltaplus
epitech et alstom brignoud qui sont
justement intéressés ça ce sont des
informations qui nous viennent du haut
fonctionnaire de défense du 13 octobre
2005 je tiens bien évidemment ces
documents à votre disposition parce que
là ça permet de voir où ils commencent à
produire des l'talie deltalyo était à
roanne par exemple macopharma à
tourcoing bacou-dalloz en bretagne delta
plus c'était sur toulouse et epitech
c'était sur la bretagne
donc voilà où sont les projets
d'implantation avec des projets dans les
différentes régions et des projets qui
sont capables d'être opérationnel très
rapidement
certains comme bacou-dalloz pouvant
aller à 150 millions de masques par an
24 heures sur 24 365 jours en cas de
crise
macopharma 150 millions par an capable
d'aller 24 heures sur 24 de production
365 jours par an en cas de crise les
autres ayant des capacités de production
inférieurs et donc à partir du moment où
l'on garantit des commandes de la part
de l'état ils savent qu'ils peuvent
s'engager dans cette preuve dans cette
production
quand j'arrive et qu' il y a bien
évidemment la grippe aviaire
on me dit quand même au ministère que
nous sommes bien préparés le plan n'est
pas encore totalement élaboré mais on me
dit que c'est quelque chose d'assez
costaud et il ya un article dans le
journal du dimanche
vous retrouvez la date exacte je sais
pas si on a la date exacte de deux
professeurs de rennes et briquet qui
font un article réquisitoire
réquisitoire en montrant qu' on est loin
d'être préparés parce que toute la
dimension pratique n'a pas été
suffisamment pensés élaboré en clair on
a un très bon plan sur le papier mais un
peu un plan de papier je demande à les
rencontrer et une pose nombre de
questions sur l'état de préparation sur
la façon dont nous pourrions faire face
aux problèmes de déplacement problèmes
de déplacement l'époque on avait imaginé
contrairement confinement d'aujourd'hui
qu'il pouvait y avoir par des
embouteillages mans et je m'aperçois la
deuxième question qu'on est vraiment pas
prêt et que ce sont des experts qui ont
fait le plan mais qu'il n'y a pas
suffisamment cette vision pratique est
là quand ils sortent je demande à ce
qu'on reprenne le plan est ce qu'on les
associe eux ainsi qu'un grand nombre
d'experts c'est ce qui donnera également
suite au fameux mardigrippe animé par un
homme remarquable qui didier houssin
didier houssin directeur général de la
santé mais aussi qui deviendra dilga
délégué interministériel à la lutte
contre la grippe à la grippe aviaire il
ne quittera ses fonctions que pour
prendre la tête je ne me trompe pas de
la mairesse sur la recherche
scientifique qui a fait un travail
également remarquable et qui n'a pas
hésité justement axé mardigrippe avoir
une vision transversale et à avoir
justement l'association d'experts de
tous niveaux de tous bords tout ça a
perdu de son importance parce que à mon
sens après l'épisode h1n1 ou roselyne
bachelot je crois que ça a été dit a été
injustement vilipendé y compris et
beaucoup dans cette assemblée
dans cet incident cette assemblée n'a eu
le sentiment qu'on en avait fait trop et
puis tous a coûté bien cher et que quand
on en fait trop et que ça coûte cher
c'est peut-être le moment de faire des
économies lieu des auditions au sénat
qui ont été aux mairies qu il y a eu des
débats notamment dont jean pierre door a
été témoin notamment en ce qui me
concerne ministre en novembre 2011
j'ai le compte-rendu justement avec la
commission des finances avec une députée
de l'aisne à l'époque était rapporteur
du texte où on nous imposait de faire
des économies notamment sur le
fonctionnement de l'eprus je me suis
expliquée à chaque fois pour maintenir
les
les moyens nécessaires mais toujours est
il qu'il y avait cette ambiance je crois
que jean yves grall vous a très bien
expliqué dans son audition entre le
risque sanitaire et les contraintes
budgétaires
on était loin d époque que j'ai connu
avec jacques chirac avec nicolas sarkozy
ou la santé passait avant le reste j'ai
eu à faire aussi à des ministres du
budget coriace très coriace jean
françois copé françois baroin valérie
pécresse
mais c'est vrai mais c'est vrai qu'on a
toujours réussi à s'entendre parce qu'il
y avait cette prééminence de la centaine
jeu souvent été raillé pour ça je suis
un assureur de profession un assureur
doit prévoir les risques doit essayer
d'anticiper parce que quand il y un
sinistre il faut aussi être bien couvert
peut-être que ça a joué dans mes
fonctions ministérielles certainement
peut-être et puis d'autre part je pense
que le rôle d'un politique c'est prévoir
le scénario du pire et ce scénario du
pire c'est d'essayer d'imaginer ce qui
peut se produire dans les circonstances
alors dans nos plans pandémie qui avait
d'ailleurs été soulignée salué par l'om
est à l époque il ya des choses quand je
vois notamment ce qui s'est passé avec
la crise terrible du coc vide c'est que
derrière on n'avait pas imaginé qu'on
pouvait sur des phases aussi longue être
confronté un tel problème de risque de
pénurie de médicaments de réanimation
curare et autres compte tenu de la durée
ça ce sont des choses qui n'étaient pas
présentes dans le plan à l'époque nous
avions prévue des vagues de vagues qui
pouvait faire 90 jours chacune
donc on avait prévu pour les masquer on
avait prévu pour les équipements on
avait anticipé un certain nombre de
choses mais vous ne l'anticipé jamais
tout c'est vrai aussi que ces implants
la première mouture est en 2006 il sera
changé il sera amélioré
en suite jean-pierre dorand parlerait
mieux que moi mais tous n'avaient pas
été prévus mais c'est vrai que tout ceci
a perdu de son importance pour les
raisons que je vous ai je vous
expliquais et notamment sur la question
des fameuses contraintes contraintes
budgétaires et après vous avez fait
allusion à mes propos du 12 juin
mes propos du 12 juin touche à une
opération est assez particulière qui
n'est pas une dotation en masques des
professionnels de santé
c'est une dotation en masque que j'ai
voulu dans la région nous sommes deux
régions à l'avoir mise en place
la région auvergne rhône alpes et la
région des hautes france
je me suis lancé dans un pari qui était
de pouvoir mettre à disposition de
l'ensemble de la population des masques
de protection masques de tissus et
masques chirurgicaux masque au tissu
lavable produits en france et masques
chirurgicaux qui jusqu'à jusqu'à
maintenant ne sont pas ne sont pas
produits en france pour le grand public
parce que les capacités de production
ont été réquisitionnés si je ne me
trompe pas à partir du début du mois de
mars par le gouvernement par le
gouvernement français donc
et quand je l'indiquais c'est que la
région c'est pas son boulot normalement
c'est le rôle de l'état
mais j'avais voulu le faire parce que je
voyais bien qu'il y avait beaucoup de
gens qui dans les hauts de france avait
des difficultés pour se procurer des
masques et qui surtout été obligé de
dépenser très très cher pour se procurer
des masses d'une opération qui a
commencé à partir du 11 mai parce
qu'avant il y avait effectivement le
confinement et c'est une opération ou
quand vous devez acheminé au total 18
millions de masques entre les masque en
tissu et les masques chirurgicaux dans
3800 communes partenaires logisticiens
c'est quand même un sacré métier c'est
quand même un sacré métier on a réussi
sa pas été simple il ya eu parfois des
retards de production il est parfois des
retards de livraison
mais en tout et pour tout on a mis à
disposition de la population ce qui a
permis notamment beaucoup de personnes
d'avoir ces masques gratuitement et de
ne pas être prise au dépourvu si elle
avait besoin soit se rendre des
commerces soit d'utiliser justement les
transports en commun donc c'est
clairement ce à quoi je fais allusion
sur la question de la logistique
je pourrais revenir sur les questions
logistiques qui ont été celles de
l'acheminement notamment au coeur de la
crise pour les professionnels de santé
et la région elle même parce que très
tôt j'ai voulu constituer des stocks de
masques de masques chirurgicaux
on a distribué un peu plus d'un million
six cent mille masques à la fois peau
parfois des professionnels de santé
parfois en soutien de la rs également
pour les forces pénitentiaires également
pour les forces de police forces de
sécurité et également pour un certain
nombre de professionnels qui se
retrouvaient en pénurie
je pense notamment l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui à un moment donné
était en grande difficulté pour lui
permettre de continuer à tourner mais
les problèmes de logistique auquel fait
allusion dans cet article du 12 juin
c'est propre à l'opération un masque
pour tous organisée par la région d
autres ans est ce qu'il ya eu un
changement de doctrine en 2011
ce que tout le monde nous avons les
chiffres et c'est pas la peine de les
citer il s'élève à plusieurs milliards
de masques
lorsque vous étiez ministre dans cette
période lorsque roselyne bachelot les
l'été puis après il ya une inversion et
il ya une diminution qui est constante
une quasi-disparition des ffp2 total en
janvier 2020 ghana 0 il y en a plus et
puis sur les masques chirurgicaux on
arrive à se chiffre autour de 100
millions un peu moins selon santé
publique france un peu plus selon la dgs
en début de crise m'enfin en tout cas
des stocks qui ne permettent pas de
couvrir deux à trois jours de crise pour
la population générale selon les
évaluations qui avait été faite voilà
comment est ce qu'il y a eu
véritablement et sous votre autorité
donc sous votre décision ce un
changement de doctrine à cette époque en
2011 qu'est ce qui se passe
en 2011 vous avez un avis du haut
conseil de la santé publique relatif à
stratégie adoptée concernant le stock
d'état de masques respiratoires
quand je quitte mes fonctions ce ne sont
pas mes propos qui font foi mais les
notes des directeurs généraux de la
santé à ce moment précis il y à 1
milliard 400 millions de masques en
france qui se répartissent grosso modo
600 millions de masques ffp2 et 800
millions de masques chirurgicaux et la
doctrine qui est porté par l'avis du
haut conseil de la santé publique ne
vise que là dessus donc ça n'est
absolument pas un changement de doctrine
sur le nombre de masques c'est tout
simplement une recommandation qui dit le
ffp2 pour les professionnels de santé et
pour tous les autres c'est effectivement
du masque chirurgical
disons les choses très clairement c'est
un problème d'argent
quasiment du début jusqu'à la fin le
problème numéro un que nous avons
rencontrés c'est la question de la
pénurie des masques et la pénurie des
masques à fixer en quelque sorte la
doctrine public et pourquoi il ya eu
pénurie parce que des masques il faut
s'en occuper et des masques il faut les
acheter
voilà c'est un problème de vigilance
vous l'avez dit vous-même et c'est un
problème de moyens budgétaires la
question qui se pose c'est est-ce que la
santé passe au dessus du reste
oui
non et est ce que les logiques
financières comptables et court termisme
ça doit nous empêcher d'être
suffisamment protégé moi j'ai ma réponse
c'est non
et voilà aujourd'hui pourquoi on en est
arrivé là et ce au fil des années au fil
des années et plus que de pointer la
responsabilité de l'un ou de l'autre
c'est tout un système qui s'est fait
bouffer la tête par ces logiques court
termiste et c'est logique budgétaire et
comptable
parlons maintenant de l'instruction
ministérielle que je signe l'instruction
ministérielle que je signe et qui fait
une différence je reprends vos mots
monsieur le rapporteur entre des stocks
stratégiques et des stocks tactique où
il est décidé de mettre dans justement
au plus près du terrain pour des raisons
d'efficacité des stocks tactique à
proximité notamment dans les fameux psm
qui sont les jeux s'est jamais droit à
un prêt mais que les abréviations je
déteste ça non je pense que j'ai un
problème lé poste sanitaire mobile
donc c'est bien ça sauf que dans les
stocks tactique il n'a jamais été prévu
qu'il vienne masque dans l'instruction
ministérielle de 2011
il n'y a pas de masquer les masques
resteront toujours dans les stocks
stratégiques
il n'y a pas de partition entre ces
masses dit ni dans mon instruction ni
dans l' annexe intervient autre chose
mais ça c'est en 2013 parce qu'en 2013
j'avais une doctrine de protection des
travailleurs face aux maladies hautement
pathogène à transmission respiratoire
qui a été établi le 16 mai 2013 par le
secrétariat général de la défense
nationale et qui pressait sap achète
dans le point 6 la chose suivante il
revient à chaque employeur de déterminer
l'opportunité de constituer des stocks
de masques pour protéger son personnel
qui est l'employeur des personnels
hospitaliers les hôpitaux et l'état qui
est l'employeur des professionnels
libéraux
à partir de cette date vous rentrez dans
un trou noir avec des bagarres entre eux
le ministère du budget et le ministère
de la santé et au sein du ministère de
la santé entre la direction de la
sécurité sociale et l'assurance maladie
type épaule et libéraux ce n'est pas le
ministère de la
tu es qui a élaboré cette doctrine c'est
une doctrine le sgdn est rattaché à
matignon
et c'est une doctrine qui de toute façon
va au bout de la logique qui était en
germe dans tous les débats poste h1n1
tout ça coûte trop cher et le ministère
de la santé en a trop fait et il fallait
pas non plus que ce soient pilotés
uniquement par le ministère de la santé
si je vous donne aussi l'envers des
cartes toutes ces années ont été aussi
un peu d'aidé des luttes d'influencé des
luttes d'influencé le ministère de la
santé avait pu à l'occasion de ces
crises constitué justement des stocks
très importants avait pu bénéficier de
la bienveillance notamment les
présidents des présidents de la
république et un moment donné il ya
l'idée quand même sur ces sujets sérieux
qui sont des sujets stratégiques des
sujets régaliens j'ai dit tout à l'heure
de reprendre la main et à partir du
moment où le sgdn reprend la main la
santé ne pilote plus totalement à une
exception près c'est qu'il y à l'eprus
et le coup fatal
c'est la disparition de l'eprus nous
faisons voter une loi une loi qui est
votée le 5 mars 2007 du des toutes
dernières lois le sénat accepte de se re
convoqué pour pouvoir la beauté sur les
menaces sanitaires graves avec des
décrets qui seront publiés en juin il
avait été préparé en parallèle de la loi
et cette loi dit clairement la chose
suivante parce que je pense que la
responsabilité politique ne se partage
pas et ne se délègue pas la
responsabilité politique elle est pleine
et entière et il est bien précisé que
c'est le ministre ou son représentant
c'est à dire le dgs donc quand je dis
bien le ministre ou son représentant qui
fixe chaque année les moyens clairs
adopter pour doter les prusse et pour
fixer également le nombre de masques
qu'il y aura besoin de commander pour
atteindre les objectifs cibles le moment
où il est établi que c'est à chacun de
payer ces masques
c'est effectivement en mai 2013 avec un
gdn qui reprend la main et je vous le
dis aussi c'est aussi le
début de la fin parce que à partir de ce
moment là qui va s'assurer que tout le
monde est bien au courant qu'il doit se
doter lui-même de ces masses la grande
distribution
qu'est ce qui a été fait justement pour
l'heure indiquée et vous devez avoir des
masques mais en tout état de cause quand
je vois aussi le tribut qu'on payait les
professionnels santé des libéraux le
nombre de malades ceux qui sont aussi
morts je pense que c'est aussi dans les
fonctions régaliennes que d'assurer la
protection de ceux qui nous protège et
de protéger effectivement ce qui nous
soigne une question là vous venez
d'évoquer la responsabilité du ministre
dans la loi de 2007
est ce qui vous paraît concevable
aujourd'hui puisque ça nous a été dit à
l'audition mardi soir qu'un ministre en
responsabilité ni son cabinet puisque
c'est ce qui nous a été dit n'est
connaissance du nombre du stock de
l'évaluation des stocks stratégiques de
masques ou d'autres équipements
dans mon premier passage au ministère
nous devons être 5 à 7 personnes qui
sont sur la sécurité sanitaire et je
peux vous assurer que il y avait du
boulot c'est vrai qu'on a eus
chikungunya la dengue préparation h5n1
et différentes crises sanitaires
vous pouvez me dire que c'était beaucoup
je peux vous assurer qu'il faisait
sacrément du boulot et en dehors des
horaires normaux à mon deuxième passage
au ministère vous étiez 2 sur la
sécurité sanitaire à temps plein là
aujourd'hui une personne c'est de la
folie surtout dans le monde dans lequel
on est et avec les risques que nous
connaissons un ministre doit y porter
attention et doit s'assurer aussi du
suivi surtout que depuis la loi de 2007
c'est au ministre ou à son représentant
de s'assurer justement que le nombre de
masques sera suffisant certains ont dit
que la baisse des stocks de l'eprus
révélé en fait une baisse du stock de
masques
vous pouvez préciser ce point là mais
qu'est ce qui fait qu'il ya une
variation de ses stocks en tant que tel
sur la doctrine du port du masque est ce
que vous considérez que le port du
masque est utile pour le grand public
comment cette doctrine s'est fait
pendant la chaîne
on vous l'avait vu et vous même dans la
crise du coc vide et enfin un dernier
point c'est sur la question de la
dépendance chinoise
on a été frappé dans certaines auditions
aussi que finalement ce sujet apparaît
c'est secondaire entre guillemets le
fait que finalement on dépend des que
d'un seul pays quel mécanisme d' alerte
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que c'était
très important d'avoir une production
nationale
comment qu'est-ce qui vous alerte est
pour vous quel est le seuil de
production nationale qui permet d'avoir
une certaine autonomie ou indépendance
sanitaires je voudrais savoir quel était
l'état des débats pas seulement
politique mais scientifique au lendemain
de la crise du h5n1 et plus récemment
quel jugement vous portez comme
président de région du fonctionnement d
erez de l'information qui étaient les
veaux de l'association éventuellement
qui était la vôtre à la gestion de la
crise et de ses conséquences
l'articulation avec les préfectures et
comme l'un des foyers épidémiques et
plus les plus précoces a été dans l'oise
comment selon vous a été géré ce premier
ce premier foyer merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre en 2013
vous l'avez précisé c'est de secrétaire
général de la défense et la sécurité
nationale qui décide que les masses
doivent être constituées devant les
entreprises avaient été très précieux on
voit d'ailleurs que un employeur un
grand employeur qui a 1000 2000 3000
salariés doit essayer d'estimer
d'envisager de rêver comment une crise
se passerait c'est pas son boulot il est
incapable de le faire et dans l'état on
ne prévoit pas j'ai posé plusieurs fois
la question que je me permets de revenir
là dessus pour vieillir ou dans les
services de l'état on prévoit pas qui
doit la contrôler votre préfet de région
grand préfet de la république nous a dit
qu'en réalité c'était pas prévu alors
qu'il est préfet d'une zone de défense
et c'est vrai on a le sentiment
finalement que l'administration a fini
par s'auto gérer et vous avez déclaré
dans le monde qu' il y avait
manifestement une volonté de sgdsn de
prendre le pas sur le ministère et sur
le politique que vous étiez battu contre
ça avez vous le sentiment qu'en réalité
à partir de 2013 celle inverse qui se
produit
l'économiste de la santé claude le pen
dit le point décisif c'est le sgdsn
il joue un rôle occulte je pense que
pour notre commission enquête comme nous
l'avons vu en 2010 sur la vaccination
h1n1
c'est dans le secrétariat général de la
défense et de la sécurité nationale
on doit aller regarder la qualité la
validité l'opérationnalité des plans et
là le politique reprend tout son sens
est ce que les politiques ont dirigé
d'administration où est ce que
l'administration s'est fourvoyé d'après
vous mais bien sûr qu'il ya pas eu d
accompagnement de la doctrine parce que
à la limite si vous établissez une
nouvelle doctrine chacun paye ses
masques mais que vous aller jusqu'au
bout de la logique mais l'annoncé
conditions là il faut que ce soit
interministériel et que vous dites aux
grandes entreprises dans les grands
secteurs d'activité vous dites aux
libéraux voilà exactement comment ça va
se passer
voilà ce que vous devez faire et on
regarde parce que secrétaire général de
la défense nationale rattaché à matignon
là dans ces cas là ça peut être un choix
c'est pas celui que j'aurais fait mais
ça peut être un choix mais on va
jusqu'au bout de la logique et la
question qui se pose c'est que cette
nouvelle doctrine de 2013 comment elle a
été connue comment elle a été
accompagnée
je le dis très clairement je n'imagine
pas un ministère de la santé produire
une telle doctrine n'imagine pas c'est
tout simplement parce que on est sur une
autre logique et nouvelle logique qui
fait suite à ce que je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure la question d'une moindre
préoccupation pour toutes ces questions
et puis la question aussi de la logique
budgétaire parce que quand c'est chaque
employeur qui paye ses plus l'état qui
paye c'est aussi simple que cela
mais ce fait des économies de trois
francs six sous et au bout d'un moment
vous avez aussi un drame
en 2007 le ministre de la santé que je
suis dans une note à dominique de
villepin du 9 février 2007 que je lui
indique je fais un tableau récapitulatif
des besoins et commandes de chaque
ministère en masques ffp2 et à dire que
le ministère de la santé ne se contente
pas d'établir clairement ce que nous
devons avoir comme masque pour le
périmètre santé mais on indique
notamment que en fonction des vagues
épidémiques que j'ai défilé tout à
l'heure que pour l'intérieur
il devrait y avoir un objectif de 20
millions 328 1680 masque 5 millions
quatre cent cinquante 7400 pour la
justice 4 millions huit cent cinquante
mille pour les finances l'agriculture 3
millions cent quarante et un mille la
culture pour les établissements
culturels sous tutelle les affaires
étrangères la défense 35 millions 100
mille masques la fonction publique
l'outre-mer l'éducation nationale 8
millions 105 me masse pour un pur pour
un total de masques qui se situera entre
eux
60 et 80 millions quand tout le monde a
fait ses commandes
donc voyez on se mêle un peu de ce qui
nous regarde pas ce qui plaît modérément
à l'époque mais la chiraquie lyon
prépare
comment on doit être préparé et donc on
établit ses besoins la question qui se
posera ensuite à qui vérifie que
l'ensemble des ministères s'est bien
doté
c'est toute la question parce que ce qui
est vrai c'est que le ministère de la
santé en préparant ce plan pandémique
est un peu sorti de son rôle sauf que
j'étais conscient qu'à un moment donné
le ministère de la santé n'était pas
celui qui était le plus structuré et on
l'avait vu dans des exercices grandeur
nature qui avait été fait au bout d'un
an faut remettre les clés à beauvau au
ministère de l'intérieur au ministère de
l'intérieur
mais il y avait toute cette phase
préparatoire qui était notre boulot et
ensuite il y avait la volonté de retrait
de transmettre justement à ceux qui
étaient les plus opérationnels sur le
sur le sur le territoire honnêtement
c'est au préfet de s'occuper tout ça
c'est au préfet moi j'ai un très bon
directeur général d'aer s mais le
problème c'est la structure drs alors
pour être tout à fait franc en septembre
dernier déjà lors d'une rencontre de
professionnels de santé jugé qu'il
fallait changer beaucoup de choses sur
les ars avant cette crise sanitaire les
trop grands s'occupent de trop de choses
or dans notre pays les préfets ça tient
et ça tient bien sûr votre autre
question est ce qu'on en a trop fait et
cachait non non non parce que il est
toujours beaucoup plus facile de
revisiter les choses après mes cordes
h1n1 commence si je ne me trompe pas ce
au mexique et au mexique on ne sait pas
quelle est la souche on ne sait pas
exactement comment ça peu comment ça
peut partir et on peut se trouver avec
h5n1 mais là pour de vrai avec un vrai
développement
hélas si c'est le cas roselyne bachelot
a totalement raison de prévoir la
préparation du pays comme elle prévoit
la préparation du pays et en plus les
budgets au bc bah oui tout simplement
parce que l'achat henin vous avez dû
faire des acquisitions massives de
vaccins de matériels et autres que vous
n'avez plus besoin de faire après mais
vous savez après il y aussi un critère
j'ai eu à préparer le pays et notamment
avec la dimension des masques depuis le
début pourquoi j'aurais fait
exact contraire de ce que j'avais
commencé à bâtir et après il ya une
autre question que je me pose et si
vraiment les doctrines de 2011 avait
tout changé et avait tout cassé
pourquoi deux présidents de la
république quatre premiers ministres si
je ne me trompe pas trois ministres de
la santé
si cette doctrine n'était pas la bonne
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir changé moyer des
doctrines ministériel qui ne m'ont pas
convenu comme j'étais ministre j'ai
changé des choses c'est aussi la
responsabilité du politique
moi il ya une question qui revient sans
cesse c'est comment on a pu en arriver
là
mais à votre avis quelles ont été les
décisions qu'il aurait fallu prendre et
qui n'ont pas été prises au moment où ce
pays a été impacté comme il l'a été
la seconde chose on a eu le sentiment en
écoutant les différents patrons des
agences notamment santé publique france
qu' il y avait un écran assez opaques
entre cabinets ministériels
le ministre la ministre et puis ces
agences qui ont souvent attendu moi j'ai
une phrase encore plusieurs en tête dans
ses auditions à porter s'en souvient on
a écrit au cabinet pour savoir si la
doctrine été bonifiée on n'avait pas de
réponse et que ça me laisse quelques
part vraiment sur ma faim et la
troisième question monsieur le ministre
c'est sur l'organisation territoriale
vous niez d'y faire référence et que les
ars et vous êtes patron de région qu'est
ce qu'on tire comme conséquence et comme
le sont pour que sa surprise ici parce
que nouvelle pandémie arriveront et
depuis des dizaines d'années il ya eu
des pandémies dans le dos de pays dans
le monde entier donc on doit s'y
préparer
enfin sur les tests en particulier
quelle est votre vision de cette
impréparation de la france par rapport à
notre grand voisin kehl allemagne
et si vous aviez en charge qu'auriez
vous fait merci il ya un certain nombre
de contradictions que vous avez pointé
par rapport aux auditions que nous avons
pu faire
précédemment par exemple l'intervention
de ce conseil scientifique pour vous
c'est une bonne chose
on a le sentiment que l'état était
clients des agences et que parfois les
agences en plus de pouvoir que ministère
de la santé mais en même temps que au
fil de la crise l'état lui-même ça on
est passé de ses agences et qu'il les a
contourné
vous voyez ces sentiments un peu
contradictoire c'est en tout cas sur la
manière de piloter
quel est votre regard deuxièmement est
ce que l'état ne s'est pas reposé sur
les collectivités territoriales est ce
que le fait que vous ayez été amenés à
faire des commandes
ça révèle une forme de défaillance
comment faut-il organiser tout cela est
ce qu'il faut être attentif à la
centralisation d'un certain nombre de
tâches ou ou continuer à aller dans la
direction de ce qui s'est fait pendant
l'avant dans la gestion de la crise
troisième élément si la lettre dont vous
avez peut-être entendu parler de du
directeur général de santé publique
france françois bourdillon le 26
septembre 2018 avait été envoyé à votre
directeur général de la santé qui
s'élève donc à firmin qui est un
problème dans les stocks dans la gestion
des stocks
voilà est-ce que si à cette époque là
votre directeur général de la santé
avaient été saisis de quelle suite
cela aurait été donnée en fin d'après
vous est-ce que le confinement était
évitable si les pandémies auquel vous
avez dû faire face s'était développée
plus que ce que ça n'a été le cas c'est
sous votre responsabilité au ministère
de la santé que s'est opérée la
préparation du changement de doctrine
concernant les stocks de masques
madame bachelot à constituer ses stocks
pour permettre de faire face à la grippe
h1n1 des stocks lui ont valu de
nombreuses attaques car ils n'ont pas
été employés une commission denquête qui
lui a fait le procès de vouloir servir
les industriels
ma question est simple en réorientant
des stocks en deux catégories tactiques
et stratégiques bon j'ai bien entendu
vos propos mais si on se défait d'une
catégorie on diminue les achats et la
logique financière en découle donc je
pense qu'il y avait une logique
comptable j'aimerais vous entendre sur
ce point comme je ne saurais imaginer
que vous auriez renoncer à intéresser à
la nation pour défendre certains
intérêts en amont de l'élection
présidentielle de l'époque je vous
demanderais plus simplement quelles sont
les raisons rationnelles qui font que
vous entamez donc cette réorganisation
dans le cadre de cette fameuse
instructions de novembre 2011
réorganisation que je rappelle qu'ils
n'étaient pas préconisé par le rapport
du haut conseil de la santé publique et
c'est tout de même cette décision qui a
conduit à ce qu'il n'y ait plus de
masques pour la population je vous
remercie vous parlez du stock de masques
le stock de masques en france il est
constitué à partir de 2006 et je les dis
aux moments d'achat ena on a manqué de
rien ce qui a donc montré que l'état de
préparation de la france face à une
crise majeure qui a duré bien longtemps
nous a permis justement de tenir la
deuxième chose je vous l'indiquais tout
à l'heure et je voudrais qu'on puisse
transmettre la photocopie l ensemble des
membres et notamment à madame la députée
dans cette instruction je voulais dit
tout à l'heure
elle fait suite à la création des ars il
n'est pas question de masques dans des
stocks tactique madame la députée donc
clairement ce qu'il y ait en 2011 madame
la députée peut-être c'est ce que l'on
vous a dit
si vous n'avez pas lu cette note il n'y
a aucun changement même après achat et
n'a pour moi on faisait pas d'économie
sur le dos de l'eprus sur le
fonctionnement de l'eprus et sur la
préparation du pays face aux réserves
sanitaires sur la question du conseil
scientifique
je connais bien le président du conseil
scientifique je vais nommer à
différentes fonctions autres quand
j'étais ministre de la santé
c'est quelqu'un d'éminemment respectable
le problème qui est posé c'est le
suivant mais qui décide en démocratie si
lucide scientifiques ou les politiques
est-ce que la date d'entrée en
confinement a été lié à la date du
premier tour des élections municipales
c'est une question que je me pose et
j'aimerais avoir cette réponse et pour
le reste les conditions de confinement
sont est liée à la pénurie parce que
nous nous racontons pas d'histoires
beaucoup des doctrines que nous avons
eues que nous avons entendu que nous
avons reçues sont liées à la pénurie que
ce soit les tests comme les masques et
quand vous me demandiez sur l'attitude
des pouvoirs publics
très franchement il ya des pays qui s'en
sont plus plus mal sorti que nous les
piques sur sont mieux sortis mais ça ne
sert à rien de chercher adressé à un
tableau noir ce que je vois surtout
c'est qu'il ya des dizaines et dizaines
de familles qui ont été endeuillées qui
ont perdu un des leurs et d'autres qui
ont été soit rasées par le travail
soient rasées par ce satané virus
je pense que c'est ça le phénomène le
le plus le plus important à noter mais
je veux quand même aller un peu plus
loin c'est l'attitude que nous devons
avoir avec nos concitoyens faut jamais
les infantiliser jamais parce que c'est
une main c'est un manque de respect je
pense clairement et sincèrement que s'il
avait été dit en un problème avec les
masques
nous n'avons pas assez nous n'avons pas
assez et donc en priorité ils seront
réservés aux hospitaliers et que par
exemple pour les libéraux et autres on
va faire le maximum et en priorité pour
les hospitaliers et le président a
utilisé la notion de guerre contre le
virus
alors d'accord mais c'est à la guerre
comme à la guerre on dégage tous les
process administratifs
on comprend dans l'industrie ce qui est
capable de produire des masses on a
produit beaucoup de masques mais ça a
été le système d'essai les français qui
ont été remarquables formidable tiassé
français qu'on dit querelleurs
chamailleurs indisciplinés et mondial
ont fait le succès du confinement
c'était à la fois la peur et la
sidération qui a joué c'est vrai mais
ils ont été là les français
toutes ces initiatives de solidarité où
sont fabriqués des maths
sauf que ont leurs effets au niveau
industriel et pas seulement sur les
respirateurs on aurait pu aussi doté les
uns les autres
mais là on entendu que tu as sont les
masques étaient pas utile et je vais
revenir à la question qui m'étaient
posées sur l'utilité du port du masque
ou que on serait pas les mettre je pense
que les français peuvent tout en tendant
des circonstances exceptionnelles faut
juste qu'on leur dise la vérité je n'ai
pas les informations dont disposait le
priant de la république et le premier
ministre à informations parfois
contradictoires
et puis dans des crises comme celle ci
j'ai eu en affrontait notamment le le le
chikungunya qui était très différent
mais y avait aussi le drame humain les
disparitions alors qu'on nous avait dit
aussi que normalement il n'y avait pas
de morts et à l'époque j'avais eu cette
phrase les scientifiques me disent que
le chikungunya n'est pas mortelle
moi je voudrais être sûr le lendemain on
apprenait les premiers essais
comme quoi toutes les certitudes en la
matière toutes les certitudes mais je
pense qu'il faut dire au maximum les
choses aux gens et qu'ils peuvent tout
entendre et qu'ils peuvent tout entendre
le ministère de la santé peut s'occuper
des choses jusqu'à un certain niveau je
pense qu'au bout d'un moment c'est pas
le dgs qui peut piloter c'est un délégué
interministériel à la lutte contre
parce que cette dimension
interministérielle avec un rattachement
direct au premier ministre permet
d'avoir cette dimension
interministérielle à vous savez il ya
toujours les ministères qu'ils peuvent
regarder le ministère de la santé un peu
dit un peu différemment
même si quand il a pris ses fonctions
olivier ferrand a vraiment pris ses
fonctions à plein avec un temps
d'adaptation qui a été réduit réduit à à
quasiment rien il a pris il a assumé ses
responsabilités mais oh il faut cette
dimension interministérielle
j'en suis intimement convaincu j'en suis
j'en suis persuadé et le dgs tout seul
ça ne suffit pas sur la question du
rapport avec les collectivités locales
il y a eu sur le coeur du confinement
sur le déconfinement les l'état a plutôt
travaillé avec les mairies avec les
mairies peut-être que l'état à penser
que les régions ne s'occupait que de
transport s'occuper que des lycées et de
l'avenir sur économique on n'a pas été
des partenaires privilégiés
on a eu dans la région une parfaite
coopération public privé
et puis j'ai aussi eu à passer un
certain nombre de messages pour des
professionnels de santé quand on
risquait d'avoir des problèmes de
pénurie je suis certainement sorti de
mes fonctions j'ai pas joué au ministre
de la santé je l'indiquais il ya qu un
ministre de la santé en france s'appelle
olivier ferrand j'ai fait passer ses
messages ses messages ont été vraiment
entendu donc on a eu un écosystème qui a
fait qu'on a été parmi les premiers
touchés
nous avons eu des victimes c'est là où
il ya eu aussi le premier médecin qui
est mort le système de santé français ou
même parler des équipements vous avez
raison vous même parler des traitements
vous avez raison pas de problème mais
c'est les personnels c'est ça qui fait
la vraie différence sur la doctrine du
port du masque c'est dans le plan
gouvernemental de prévention et de lutte
pandémie grippale qui n'a jamais été
remis en cause
jamais été remis en cause à la page 43
de la fiche technique du 18 janvier 2006
si vous ne l'avez pas je peux peut-être
vous la laissez monsieur le rapporteur
important il est bien précisé notamment
les niveaux d'équipement pour les
activités du type familial on avait été
jusqu'à ce niveau de détail personnes
vivant dans l'entourage immédiat d'un
cas suspect ou avéré et contribuera ses
souhaits masques anti-projections
personnes vivant dans l'entourage
immédiat d'un cas suspect masques
anti-projections personnes se rendant
dans les lieux publics masques anti
projections ou masques grand public
à l'époque en 2006 on n'a pas encore les
masques lavables
nous ont sollicités industriels pour
qu'ils le fassent mais en 2006 il n'ya
pas encore c'est soit du ffp2 soit du
masque chirurgical mais on n'a pas
encore les masques lavables en tissu
personnes se déplaçant transports en
commun masques anti-projections au
masque grand public
les intervenants exposés régulièrement
public ffp2 intervenants peuvent exposer
régulièrement à des cas suspects ou
avérés ffp2 et gants de protection et
les intervenants peuvent être ou sont en
contact étroit et des cas suspects ou
avérés ou des prélèvements issus de tels
cas ffp2 grande protection lunettes de
protection vêtements de protection
c'est exactement ce qui est prévu dans
le plan et ceci n'aura jamais été remis
en cause et par ailleurs je voulais
aussi vous vous l'indiquer sur la
question des des professionnels de santé
pour faire le lien avec ce que je disais
tout à l'heure quand je pense que c'est
l'état qui doit clairement assumé la
protection de l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé
c'est une décision constante chez chez
moi et c'est la raison pour laquelle en
janvier 2007 en tant que ministre de la
santé
j'adresserai à 400 mille professionnels
de santé dans toute la france un kit de
protection
un kit de protection pour leur permettre
d'avoir une toute première ligne de
protection et d'une façon à ne pas être
soumis aux problèmes de logistique et
d'acheminement par les ars ou parler les
autres les autres prestataires première
question est ce que dans votre région
des hautes france vous avez déjà un peu
abordé le sujet là j'adore le
fonctionnement en tout cas été fluide
avec l' agence régionale de santé
j'aimerais que vous reveniez sur cette
fonctionnement aviez vous dans votre
région des lits vides dans les cliniques
privées c'est important il y a eu
énormément de patients transférés à
l'étranger ou dans d'autres régions par
le biais de tgv sanitaire qu'elle était
quelle était la situation dans votre
dans votre région
un vrai dysfonctionnements sur la
transversalité était ce parce qu'il ya
une divergence au plus haut sommet une
insuffisance au niveau du ministère de
la santé selon vous est peut-être un
premier ministre qui
qui n'est pas en phase avec avec son
président qu'en pensez vous bravo pour
votre mémoire qui visiblement plus
précises sur des événements d'il ya dix
quinze ans que certains leur successeur
j'avais quatre questions en tant que
président de région frontalière que
pensez vous de la fermeture des
frontières
est ce que on aurait dû le faire avant
ou est-ce que été prises dans le jeu
dirait dans le bon calendrier
deuxièmement par rapport à des
témoignages qui ont été faits devant
cette commission denquête de conflit
d'intérêts avec des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques en lien notamment avec
le comité scientifique est ce que dans
vos fonctions de ministre vous avez pu
je dirais voire des risques qui
existaient de ce domaine là et qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire je dirais pour qu'est
ce qu'on aurait dû faire ou qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire
quel est votre avis là-dessus vous avez
parlé de garantie des commandes qui
permettait d'assurer un écosystème
producteurs de masquer le fait que nous
n'ayons pas retrouvé d'entreprise qui
fabriquait des masques à la sortie de
cette crise ne montre que cette garantie
de commandes n'a pas existé est ce qu'il
existait des documents juridiques qui
formaliser cet engagement de l'état pour
que celui-ci s'engage à reconstituer les
stocks stratégiques de masques enfin
vous avez cité le document de 2006 sur
la stratégie qui parlait donc des
masques en 2014 le document orsan ne
parle pas du tout des masques c'est la
stratégie
donc en cas de risque épidémiologique
est ce que vous pensez que est ce que
dans les documents qu'ils existent et de
votre époque il y avait un volet masque
est ce que ça vous semble normal que ces
masques et étaient oubliées en 2014 pour
la question de la fermeture des
frontières
ça aurait pu être pris effectivement un
peu plus tôt c'est vrai et d'ailleurs
dans différents exercices
gouvernementaux différents exercices
européen
je m'étais un peu singulariser parce que
dans des exercices
j'avais été premier à proposer justement
une fermeture des frontières anticipées
pourquoi la fermeture des frontières
n'empêche pas la diffusion du virus
mais elles retardent l'arrivée et elle
permet de mettre sous tension est en
état de préparation votre système de
santé j'ai toujours pensé que le masque
était indispensable et que nous
évoluerons dans la sur la question du
port du masque et vous comment s'est
beaucoup moqué de touristes asiatiques
pendant des années qui venait justement
france qui avait peur d'être contaminés
ou pour les pics de pollution sauf que
l'on oublie une chose c'est que le
masque avant tout ça une porte et
altruiste le masque c'est moins pour se
protéger pour l'heure pour les gens que
pour protéger les autres et c'est ça
qu'on a tendance à oublier
et je pense que nous changerons nos
habitudes par rapport au port du masque
je suis à peu près sûr et certain et
notamment même sur le gel
hydroalcoolique que nous changerons nos
attitudes par rapport à l'hygiène et la
santé que nous allons y avoir davantage
recours que les enfants ont pris
beaucoup plus l'habitude de se laver les
mains et que peut-être que dans les
épidémies de gastro entérite le seront
frappez qu'avant mais il faudra si je
peux me permettre on est peut-être
éloigné de ça mais vous me posez la
question qu'on revoie les règles de la
commande publique parce que l'ugap par
exemple a été capable sur différents
exemples de flinguer les filières
économiques complètes pour presse qu'il
fallait acheter à 10 centimes moins cher
ma doctrine personnel sur le port du
masque est justement de continuer à
valoriser à valoriser sa place parce
qu'il ya rien de pire que les décisions
soient prises en ne faisant pas
abstraction des intérêts financiers
c'était le sens de la loi sur le
médicament que j'ai fait voter
justement en 2012 sur 2012 qui posait
vraiment les règles de cette
transparence et d'une nouvelle forme
d'étanchéité mais je voulais dire une
loi votée c'est bien il doit respecter
c'est mieux sur la question du
fonctionnement et de la fluidité
même si on a eu un peu un écosystème
particulier on voit bien que sur la
question des informations on a des
présidents de départements qui ont eu le
sentiment de ne pas avoir la même
information notamment sur la question
des ehpad jeu notamment celle qui a été
en première ligne
nadège le faible après ans du conseil
départemental de l'oise qui a dû
vraiment à chaque fois se positionner
pour avoir les infos savoir ce qui se
passait comment être associés là c'est
vrai que moi j'avais pas de compétence
directe sanitaires je le déplore en tant
que président de région
mais les les départements ça pas été
simple quand même mais je pense qu'il
n'y avait pas toutes les informations il
ya peut-être aussi des consignes qui
avait été donnée qui ne rendait pas la
tâche des directeurs généraux des ars
très simple vous avez parlé de rien de
bien être et une culture
moi j'ai une crainte j'avais d'ailleurs
demandé à ce qu'il y ait un numéro
national qui soit mis en place parce que
le confinement est une épreuve le
confinement est une épreuve et je pense
que il ya beaucoup d'effet psychologique
qui ont peut-être pas été assez pris en
compte et comme je fais partie de ceux
qui sont très très préoccupés par la
rentrée dans la crise économique sa
dimension sociale qui peut aussi prendre
prendre corps sur une forme de détresse
psychologique savez le confinement ne
vit pas de la même façon quand on est
avec une très belle maison avec un beau
paysage et puis du terrain et quand on
est à quatre ou cinq dans 70 mètres
carrés
parce que même la question du
télétravail télétravail et quand vous
avez
enfin la maison c'est pas très simple
c'est pas très simple et se retrouvait
aussi avec toute cette proximité ou pas
dire autre chose c'est pas facile et je
pense que pour les personnes seules ça a
été encore plus compliqué j'aurais aimé
qu'il y anime héros aussi simple que le
18 qu'ils soient mis en place pour
justement en ligne et des initiatives
ont été mises en place mais c'est pas la
même force quand vous avez un numéro à
deux chiffres mais toute cette dimension
psychologique
elle doit continuer à être surveillé
parce que je pense qu'il ya un vrai
sujet et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui me
pourquoi j'ai plaidé pour la culture la
culture
il ya une dimension économique emploi
mais c'est beaucoup plus que ça beaucoup
plus que ça je veux faire sourire je
sais mais quand vous voyez
qu'aujourd'hui on attend toujours
l'ouverture des bals populaires de ses
guinguettes tout ça même le monde de la
nuit attend des réponses et aussi du
lien et pas seulement leur boulot qui
compte c'est tout ce lien et je pense
que la dimension psychologique est
beaucoup plus importante qu'on compte
qu'on imagine des lits vides dans les
cliniques
il y en a eu il y en a eu mais c'est
aussi parce qu'on a été très près
d'atteindre un moment donné la
saturation on s'en est approché mais
donc nous avons eu des lits vides mais
attention je n'ai pas eu dans la région
le sentiment que le privé est exclu j'ai
aussi veiller j'ai aussi indiqué dès le
début parce que nous avions un état au
début nous avions deux réunions de
réunions par semaine avec le préfet la
rs les prêts en département les
associations de maires et les pompiers
et autres qui nous permettait justement
d'avoir une vision stratégique et donc
régulièrement je posais des questions je
faisais aussi des propositions mais donc
nous n'avons pas eu de lee qui était
inutilisé tous étaient mobilisables
tous étaient mobilisables mais j'ai le
sentiment qu'il ya eu une coopération
qui aurait pu être meilleur mais qui n'a
rien à voir avec ce que j'ai entendu et
vu pour d'autres régions et je pense
notamment je pense notamment à la vôtre
il a été désarmé l'eprus lui fait du
financement et dans son autonomie
l'autonomie de l'eprus a été supprimée
alors qu'elle était dans les
recommandations de la loi sur santé
france public
il faut remettre les prusse en activité
de façon importante pour l'avenir
didier ou simple que vous connaissez
bien nous dit dans le monde s'était
finalement à ses voisins concernant
cette note ministérielle
c'est à ses voisins de ce qu'on avait
utilisé jusqu alors mais le problème
c'est qu'il y a eu un premier changement
stratégique que je considère moi plutôt
comme une erreur stratégique
dire que les masques ffp2 donc lui parle
de masques ffp2 dans cette
recommandation
c'est pour les professionnels il faut
donc que ce soit les employeurs qui les
acquièrent mais les employeurs c'est
qu'ils les appels d'offres vous voyez un
peu le bazar pour un hôpital qui a quand
même autre chose à faire la gestion des
stocks stratégiques dans la durée des
matériels donc voir donc si vous pouvez
nous donner votre avis là-dessus d'autre
part là dessus vous avez été selon aux
déclarations achats tvp de 2012 à 2015
membre du conseil du surveillance du ch
de saint quentin je voulais vous
interpellez là-dessus savoir si en
qualité de membre du conseil de
surveillance vous avez interpellé
justement sur la qualité la quantité des
stocks dans cet hôpital là je crois que
vous aviez signé vous en tout cas à
votre époque avait été signé un contrat
avec l'entreprise de plaintel qui
fabriquait des masques alors une
entreprise qui fabriquait donc jusqu'à
200 millions de masques en 2010 par an
vous l'avez dit regretter par la suite
qui a disparu en 2010 elle est rachetée
par le groupe américain honeywell et
l'état interrompt ses commandes à partir
de 2012 et contrairement aux engagements
pris dans l'article of du protocole
c'est une faillite collective distille à
cette époque là donc quelle est votre
vision sur la souveraineté sachant que
l'état à votre époque n'a pas donné
suite à ses commandes en france et a
provoqué la difficulté de cette
entreprise merci fallait-il aller au
théâtre le 9 mars 2020 fallait-il avoir
un discours qui était aussi versatile
[Musique]
alors qu'il y avait à l'évidence un
nombre conséquent de documents qui
permettaient de fixer finances doctrine
du moins une stratégie deuxième chose je
voudrais vous interroger
monsieur ministre sûr on a beaucoup
parlé de déconfinement et on a essayé
d'y trouver une solution d'ailleurs qui
était intelligente et un déconfinement
différenciées en fonction des régions
moi je suis aussi d'une région
frontalière mais même la présidente
la plus belle c'est à dire l'aquitaine
et donc il ya pratiquement rien eu chez
nous pratiquement rien eu dans mon
département absolument rien pouvait-on
envisagée où peut-on envisager parce que
je veux pas faire le procès aussi de
choses qu'on ne savait pas mais peut-on
envisager pour l'avenir un confinement
qui soient régionales un confinement qui
soit différenciée qui préserve par là
même notre économie je voudrais vue
avoir votre avis là-dessus
enfin on a parlé de l'europe mais qu'au
travers du prisme des frontières pas au
travers du prisme d'un mutualisation des
moyens
moi je voudrais avoir votre lecture de
l'absence de stratégie sanitaire de
l'union européenne
nous avons accueilli nous en met plein
atlantique des malades et tant mieux
soit l'hôpital de pau soit l'hôpital de
bayonne des malades qui venait du grand
est par contre de l'autre côté de la
frontière à 40 km nous n'avons pas
cueilli un seul malade espagnol je ne
répondrai pas sur la question du théâtre
ou autres jeux pas faire de commentaire
par contre sur le sur le rhin sur la
question du confinement territorialisée
par région si vous faites ça faut donc
prendre des mesures comme celles qui ont
été prises en italie c'est que vous
devez empêcher les transferts d'une
région à l'autre
donc il fallait dans ces conditions-là
donner de la souplesse mais aussi durcir
les différents process et les transports
pas si simple que ça à organiser mais
c'est vrai que beaucoup de régions n'ont
pas compris avec un nombre de malades
par habitant qui était très réduit des
capacités
on a connu ça au déconfinement encore
une fois vous voyez il ya des décisions
qui ont été prises pour vraiment
libérez libérez la vie libérer
l'économie qui ont été prises au
lendemain de long week-end
ou alors il fallait dire écoutez on va d
confiné totalement hollande
le week-end de la pentecôte parce que
c'est un week-end on ne veut pas qu'ils
aient trop de concentration n'avait pas
envie de sa reprise mais il faut le dire
mais dans les régions où l'épidémie
avait commencé plus tôt qu'ils étaient
plus durement frappées n'est pas non
plus facile de voir les choses quand
j'ai expliqué notamment que je
distribuerai les masques en premier dans
l'oise et l'aisne là où le virus circule
est le plus dans d'autres départements
on m'a dit pourquoi pourquoi eux en
premier voyez c'est toujours très
difficile de combiner le respect du
confinement qui a même été une
entreprise réussie même si elles étaient
très lourdes et qu'après je pense que ça
a dû jouer dans le rôle dans la décision
politique je pense on vous commandent
des masques est ce que ça vous donne une
capacité de production mais l'idée il
faut aussi que vous diversifier votre
production que vous diversifier votre
production c'est-à-dire que vous alliez
chercher aussi des clients autres que
l'état français
pourquoi le protocole n'est pas
renouvelé ma parce qu on a l'objectif
cible mois derrière je les commande de
façon à ce qu on a soit cette capacité
de production mais reconnaissait qu à
partir du moment où vous êtes à 100% de
la cible au ffp2 vous n'allez pas en
commander d'autres
donc c'est pas moi qui vais fermer la
porte ou qui déchire le contrat en 2010
je suis désolé c'est pas comme ça que
c'est pas comme ça que ça se fait pas
comme ça que ça se passe
vous m'avez parlé didier où ça mais moi
je vois absolument pas de contradiction
que la décision que prend jean yves
grall derrière parce que vous n'avez pas
l'instruction
donc je comprend dans ces cas là que
vous puissiez avoir lu que c'est en 2011
que tous avaient tout avait changé
vous allez lire l'instruction que je que
je remets mais vous verrez que dans
l'instruction il n'est pas question de
masques et donc je vois bien toute façon
la contraction qui est fait entre l'avis
du haut conseil
l'instruction ministérielle et le sgdn
de 2013 mais je sais pas pourquoi ceux
qui en parlent d'eux parle jamais de
2013 voilà donc c'est à partir de ce
moment là s'il ya un choix qui est
regrettable dans toute cette affaire je
vous le dis très clairement c'est tout
simplement qu'on ait dit que chacun
payait ses masques alors que c'est la
responsabilité de l'état font parle bien
de stocks nationaux et pas seulement de
stocks qui sont placés dans les
établissements je vous aurais donné
raison simon instruction ministérielle
avait prévu que les masques étaient dans
les stocks tactique dans les semis ou
dans les samu c'est pas le cas
attendez vous êtes en train de me dire
que moi en tant que membre du conseil de
surveillance de l'hôpital j'aurais dû
aller
comptez le nombre de matches que c'est
bien ça oui c'est bien ça d'accord faut
ne rien vous cacher avec une forme de
droit de droit de de suite si j'ai aussi
commander très tôt dès le mois de mars
des masques c'est parce que je ne
voulais pas qu'il y ait pénurie pour les
soignants et pas seulement pour les
hospitalières
et quand on a remis également à des
aides à domicile et donc dans les
fonctions qui sont les miennes même si
ce n'était pas ma responsabilité
j'ai tout fait et au moment où je vous
parle nous avons d'ores et déjà
reconstitué dans la région un stock de
plus de 16 millions de masques jetables
et nous sommes en train de constituer un
masque de plusieurs millions de masques
en tissu si jamais il y avait une
nouvelle vague ou si jamais il y avait
des piles et me et là vous voyez
monsieur le député c'est pas mon boulot
comme c'était pas mon boulot de mettre
un masque à disposition de chacun donc
je veux pas rentrer dans un vaste débat
aujourd'hui pour savoir qui devait le
faire vous savez pertinemment qu'ils
veulent faire je sais pertinemment
mais plutôt que de se lancer dans ce
procès j'ai préféré prendre les
responsabilités et les compétences qui
sont pas les miennes est ce qu'il faut à
l'eprus oui
rattaché au premier ministre a pas ce
que je voulais dit le début de la fin
c'est quand il se fait de noyés dans la
masse et qu'il réintègre le ministère de
la santé
comme je pense qu'il faudrait qu'il y
ait une loi de programmation sanitaires
sur la sécurité sanitaire d'une façon à
ne pas être dépendant mais encore une
fois est-ce que vous estimez que ça
relève du régalien ou pas ça permettrait
justement de renforcer l'autonomie
budgétaire par rapport aux
considérations qu'on peut avoir de
l'annualité budgétaire et puis ça
consacrerait aussi le fait que l'eprus
serait directement rattaché aux services
du premier ministre pour donner à la
fois de l'autorité et le côté
interministérielle qui seraient
garanties
il faudra pas se tromper pour savoir qui
on met la tête de l'eprus également noir
sur blanc dans le contrat de performance
il était prévu de s'occuper de la
qualité du renouvellement des stocks
stratégiques
ça veut dire la péremption est aussi la
qualité
avez vous pu sur votre région contribué
un dépistage massif de la population
vous nous indiquer que le directeur
général la santé que vous avez nommé
monsieur houssin devient également
délégué interministériel en même temps
est ce que je trouve plutôt très bien
parce que ça veut donc dire que c'est
porter prioritairement
mais est-ce à dire que votre
fonctionnaire de défense qui normalement
lui aussi n'a pas cette vocation
interministérielle mais hélas pour faire
en sorte que votre ministère et toujours
cette pensée de défense globale
militaires et non militaires et faire
face percolé l'esprit de défense auprès
de tous vos directeurs d'administration
centrale ne suffit pas à faire en sorte
que que que que l'option que vous prenez
n'arrive pas à convaincre qu'il faut le
renfort d'un délégué un tamis steria qui
par ailleurs est un directeur général de
la santé et qui est sans doute la
personne la plus importante de votre
ministère ne croyez-vous pas que nous
devrions mettre en place et que cette
commission denquête pourrait proposer la
mise en place d'un modèle économique
différent pour les entreprises qui
représentent des productions stratégique
qui leur permettrait de survivre puisque
visiblement nous dépendons totalement
sur un certain nombre de sujets comme
les équipements mais surtout pour tout
ce qui concerne le principe actif
les antiviraux etc ne serait ce pas la
solution est-ce que les ars ont été
efficace pendant la gestion pour la
gestion de cette crise est ce qu'elles
ont suffisamment de pouvoir est-ce qu'on
sépare est au milieu du gué
et dernière chose 10 10 salariés de
l'administratif pour 10 personnels
soignants sur le territoire dont le
domaine de la santé
et ton efficace ou sur administré plus
de pouvoir aux rs non non moi je pense
ailleurs on va voir ce que va donner le
ségur parce que moi j'ai été interrogé
comme des prêts en département les
positions moi je fais des propositions
très claires sur une décentralisation en
matière de santé donc je pense
clairement que les ars va plus et tout
ce qui relève de la sécurité sanitaire
les préfets ou sous l'autorité des
préfets c'est pas nouveau je vous dise
th à monique sur un colloque en
septembre dernier j'avais non seulement
fait les propositions en tendant la main
madame busin à l'époque avant qu'elle ne
quitte à ses fonctions elle avait dit
niet mais des propositions qui était
très étoffé qui consistait pas à dire je
veux de l'argent c'est je prends des
compétences avec une part dont dame
régionaliser un or dame l'idée notamment
québec pierre méhaignerie depuis depuis
bien longtemps
à une condition c'est que les régions
s'engagent à mettre davantage sur la
table il ya je cherche pas à récupérer
les compétences et les financements
savourez donc dire qu'il parte
rien dans lequel nous on met plus
qu'avant façon à montrer qu'on est
volontaire et qu'on est prêt à faire on
va voir si ça ce sera retenu mais je
demande pas la sécurité sanitaire ce que
prônait ce qui s'est passé en italie en
italie sur n'a pas contrôlé au tout
début je parle sous le contrôle du
rapporteur qui est voisin ce parce que
la sécurité sanitaire c'est pas l'état
c'est les régions hors ya un président
de région qui a dit qu'ils voulaient pas
faire une sorte de ségrégation
sanitaires et qui voulait pas imposer
justement un confinement à certaines
populations et certains quartiers
c'est comme ça que c'est aussi partir
pas se raconter d'histoires le sanitaire
la sécurité sanitaire c'est leur est
assez regalia pas donc il faut pas non
plus diluées diluer sa donc sur les ars
très clairement à puce sur la question
du modèle économique sur les stocks moi
je suis d'accord mais alors dans ces cas
là il faut considérer que les opérateurs
sont des opérateurs d'importance vitale
c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et que dans
ces cas là vous avez un écosystème -
cadre réglementaire économique donc
fiscal qui permet pour eux d'avoir cette
visite et et de ne pas retomber dans le
travers de pintes elle qui a fermé en
c'est ça le fond du problème c'est ça
parce que si vous aller jusqu'au bout du
raisonnement s'ils sont si importants
que ça vous leur donnent un statut
particulier et un olive est un opérateur
d'importance vitale
il fait aussi l'objet d'une surveillance
particulière de la part de l'état donc
ces infrastructures là où ces opérateurs
je pense qu'il doit avoir ce statut
parce qu'il contribue à nouveau thème il
faut aller plus loin également il faut
le faire sur un certain nombre de
médicaments relocaliser le doliprane
c'est bien mais il faut aussi
relocaliser la production de curare et
d'un certain nombre de médicaments
autour du livret a c'est ça aussi tout
l'enjeu donc moi je pense qu'il faut
dans ces conditions-là aller plus loin
que les seuls masque ou c'est mon
intérêt pour les masquer mais je pense
qu'il faut bien évidemment dans ces
conditions-là élargir très clairement
mais là il ya un vrai travail qui plus
qu'un travail de relocalisation va être
un travail de réindustrialisation de
réindustrialisation et on est au coeur
de la souveraineté et de la protection
de nos concitoyens sur la question du
fonctionnaire de défense en 2007
il ya une réforme de l'administration
centrale et c'est donc le secrétaire
général du ministère santé qui devient
le haut fonctionnaire et son adjoint est
le chef du département
des urgences sanitaires l'adjoint chef
du département urgences sanitaires
encore une fois bon peut-être qu'on à
tropisme important mais c'est ce que
l'on souhaite vraiment fixé mais ils
n'ont pas de pouvoir interministériel et
le deal gars didier houssin par son
autorité c'est pas moi qui le nomme
c'est philippe douste-blazy qu'il nomme
et bien évidemment je le confirme dans
ses fonctions et je proposerai qu'il
soit qu'il soit dit le gars mais c'est
la question du pouvoir un terme initial
après il faut aussi reconnaître les
choses c'est beaucoup une toux personnel
quand même faut retrouver un didier où
ça alors c'est pas pas si simple que ça
il très bons directeurs généraux de la
santé parce que j'ai nommé mais bon jean
yves grall quelqu'un de remarquable
qu'ils ont plus avec toute cette
expérience terrain avec les fonctions
qui avaient été les siennes on part
auparavant
mais honnêtement ce pouvoir interne
initial après nous nous racontons pas
d'histoires
le sgdn a un peu souffert des années de
préparation du plan pandémique parce que
normalement ce n'était pas au ministère
de la santé de le faire mais comme nous
avions à la fois pris le lead et nous
étions couvert par matignon et beaucoup
par l'elysée avec notamment frédéric
salat baroux qui couvrait toute cette
partie là marie-claire kg qui qui
veillait à ce que je puisse disposer des
moyens qui ont référer directement
présent chirac qui lui-même en parler
directement
je dois dire que ils n'ont pas pu faire
mais ils ont attendu le moment pour
faire et ça a été en 2013 voilà sur la
question des tests
bon autant là je pense qu'on est
vraiment encore une fois dans la
responsabilité régalienne
mais le 1er mai j'ai écrit au ministre
de la santé en mêlant monsieur le
ministre lors de sa déclaration du 28
avril 2020 devant l'assemblée nationale
le premier ministre a fixé l'objectif de
réaliser au moins 700 mille tests
virologiques par semaine a daté du 11
mai je ne t'ai avec attention vous avez
confié le 21 avril 2020 à monsieur
nicolas castle d'une mission dépistage
virologiques et sérologique au sein de
la task force mise en place pour la
gestion du volet sanitaire du
déconfinement au sein du centre de crise
sanitaire
dans la lettre de mission de monsieur
nicolas castle hill 21 avril 2020 il est
mentionné que la france a réalisé la
semaine dernière
cent quarante mille tests par semaine
soit 20000 test par jour
l'enjeu étant de passer de 20 mille
tonnes par jour à 100 milles thèse par
jour à partir du 11 mai selon les
dernières informations communiquées par
l' agence régionale de santé des os de
france en date du 25 avril
il y aurait deux mille cinq cents tests
effectués par jour sur toute notre
région avec un objectif de 7 milles par
jour 11 mai ainsi je souhaite savoir
comment va se déployer la stratégie
nationale de montée en puissance des
tests et sa déclinaison régionale tant
sur la mise en place des brigades
effectuant les prélèvements ainsi que la
réponse qui pourrait être apportée par
le gouvernement aux tensions sur les
approvisionnements nécessaires aux tests
écouvillon réactif je vous confirme que
le conseil régional est tout à fait
volontaire pour vous accompagner dans
vos efforts même s'il ya plusieurs
semaines
l' agence régionale de santé nous a
demandé de ne pas procéder à
l'acquisition de test pouvez vous me
confirmer que le nombre de tests
effectués n'influe pas sur la
classification des départements en rouge
ou en vert sur la carte sanitaire publié
c'était pas mon boulot mais j'avais pas
envie qu'on se retrouve bloqué en rouge
parce qu'on n'avait pas les tests et
donc ce que je propose clairement en
contradiction avec ce que le directeur
général de la rs me dira lors d'une
réunion publique va public notamment
stratégique où je lui dis si j'achète
des tests c'est ce que je préfère vivre
n'achetez pas été c'était aussi l'époque
il faut aussi son souvenir où le
gouvernement voulait garder les tests et
les concentrés pour faire les tests et
cerveau nettement c'est une stratégie
qui s'entend c'est une stratégie qui
sont armés mois à la fin je veux pas me
retrouver bloqué à rester en rouge parce
qu'il n'ya pas le nombre de tests la rs
me répondra je n'aurai jamais de réponse
à ce courrier
mais on comprend bien que quand nous
nous avons été sollicités par des
producteurs de tess la question de la
visibilité sur la doctrine n'était pas
simple et donc l'état nous a dit on fait
on fait mais aujourd'hui je ne sais pas
à combien on en est les tests de toute
façon je pense qu'il ya une logique est
à peu près similaire à celle des à celle
des masques à une différence notable
il ya beaucoup de gouvernements qui sont
fait balader sur la question des tests
regardez l'espagne tout ce qu'elle a
commandées elle a tout mis à la poubelle
donc c'est facile de dire les tests
voilà ce qu'il aurait fallu faire entre
sérologique les tests pcr c'était pas
facile d'avoir la vraie production
et puis alors là on était quasiment
totalement dépendante des coréens ou d
où des chinois mais je pense que là on
est sur la responsabilité de l'état
mais là ça a été compliqué d'y voir
clair sur les orientations stratégiques
qui étaient celles de l'état je voudrais
revenir sur cette doctrine du 16 mai
2013 établi par le sgdn doctrine de
protection des travailleurs face aux
maladies hautement pathogène à
transmission respiratoires et qui
établit que désormais la protection des
travailleurs relève de la responsabilité
des employeurs qu'ils soient publics ou
privés
vous l'avez dit cette doctrine n'a pas
été expliquée elle n'a pas été
accompagnée en plus son application est
incertaine puisque il revient à
l'employeur de déterminer l'opportunité
de s'équiper
pensez vous qu'il faut confier aux
hôpitaux le soin d'acquérir et de gérer
ses stocks ffb 2 ou bien faut-il revenir
à une gestion centralisée de l'état
parlent ensemble pour l'ensemble des
masques que ce soit les chirurgicaux ou
les ffp2 comment envisagez vous la
distribution de ses marques
si tel est le cas puisqu'on veut bien
vous l'avez évoqué la logistique est
complexe
quels sont les relais locaux à activer
et faut-il également développer
l'apprentissage des gestes barrières et
notamment l'hygiène des mains dès le
plus jeune âge afin d'acquérir une
culture de la prévention
donc pendant votre présence au ministère
de la santé
l'état des stocks détenus par l'eprus
est-il évaluer et à quelle cadence et
ils évalués et contrôlés donc avant nous
les dates pouvons nous pouvons nous les
avoir notamment pour les masques ffp2
qui ont une date de péremption et
quelques l ensemble donc à l'époque les
conclusions que nous puissions tirer ce
que vous pourriez nous expliquer votre
vision de la prévention des grandes
crises de demain
on a eu la crise financière avec des
amortisseurs mais bon on à la crise
sanitaire
la crise environnementale elle arrive
elle est devant nous calé quel est le
modèle je pense qu'il ya
ya jamais eu le moindre débat sur le
nombre de masques qui étaient
disponibles
année après année parce que je crois
savoir également que marisol touraine a
reconnu le nombre de masques qu'il y
avait quand elle a pris ses fonctions la
seule chose c'est que pour être tout à
fait précis il faut bien que l'on
précise à la fois le nombre de masques
ffp2 et le nombre de masques
chirurgicaux et d'ailleurs dans la note
qui est fait je pense que vous l'avez la
note du 27 juillet 2011 qui est établi
par jean yves grall directeur général de
la santé aux ministres travaillent à la
tension d'ailleurs de monsieur gressier
et de l'autre et du conseiller
budgétaire
il est précisé noir sur blanc la chose
suivante il est proposé de n'envisager
le cas échéant le renouvellement des
masques qu'à compter du ps 2013 sur la
base d'une stratégie actualisée qui
tiendra compte de l'avis du hscp voilà
donc clairement les recommence je ne
sais pas si vous l'avez monsieur
rapporté on a l'impression que vous
laisser je peux vous laisser donc qui
précise noir sur blanc et l'autre par ce
sont dans les analyses
à chaque fois du ministre fin du
ministre wallon du directeur général de
la santé que vous avez précisément le
nombre le nombre de masques donc il y a
eu un moment donné une forme d'ambiguïté
sur les crédits budgétaires mais comme
je l'expliquais tout à l'heure la baisse
des crédits budgétaires intervenait
après h1n1 dans la mesure où on n'avait
pas à reconstituer le même niveau de
vaccins et de et de matériel est par
ailleurs par ailleurs il est aussi
précisée dans le contrat de performance
je faisais tu as tout à l'heure que
l'eprus que l'eprus remet à la fin du
premier trimestre de chaque année à son
conseil d'administration un rapport
annuel d'exécution des actions
entreprises à des précédentes en vue de
la mise en oeuvre des orientations
stratégiques énuméré en annexe 1 du
présent contrat
un bilan issue du rapport annuel
d'exécution et de l'évaluation du comité
stratégique est établie par la dgs et
communiqué au conseil d'administration
de l'établissement d' assez facile de
voir qu'ils figuraient dans le conseil
d'administration est bien évidemment il
y avait il y avait il y avait l'état est
bien évidemment les orientations
stratégiques c'est la constitution des
stocks
c'est la constitution des stocks pardon
des stocks de masques
donc effectivement tout ceci est
clairement transparent suivi de prendre
les chiffres pour bien voir les
dotations mais si je peux me permettre
encore une fois sur la question du
nombre de mâts ce que c'est
le problème jusqu à un certain moment
après on va dire jeudi comme le pensiez
une boîte noire mais pendant un moment
et ce pour ça que la solidarité
particulière entre ministre de la santé
mais quand je vous dit tout à l'heure la
décision du sgdn
elle est certainement pas dictée par le
ministère de la santé dans la vie de
l'académie nationale de médecine du 22
mars 2020 dont didier houssin il
secrétaire et je pense qu'il a participé
en tenant la plume notamment ou en y
contribuant il revient justement sur la
décision de 2013 conseil c'est donc dans
le document officiel dans la ville
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur on peut supposer qu'une
instruction circulaire
interministérielle point d'interrogation
a indiqué aux professionnels de santé
libéraux aux chefs des établissements de
santé et aux responsables des
établissements du secteur médico social
qui leur incombait de se doter de stocks
de masques ffp2 pour la protection des
professionnels susceptibles d'être
exposées il s'agit bien du didier
houssin secret secrétaire et je pense
qu'il s'était lui-même exprimé justement
justement là-dessus
j'essaie de répondre le plus précisément
possible et c'est pas facile avec trois
questions à la suite le président encore
monsieur c'est pas faute de l'avoir dit
non ça parce que comme vous c'est
parfois difficile à mes collègues vous
êtes minutes ça vous arrange bien parce
que vous survolez voilà vous essayez de
parler de façon très fluide et du coup
vous répondez pas précisément question
ça vous arrange
moi je suis maintenant venu où j'essaye
de répondre aux questions voilà c'est
tout voilà c'était pas bien la façon
dont je pratiquais comme pratique
toujours d'autres mais la question
aujourd'hui j'essaye de j'essaye de
répondre précisément sur la question des
gestes-barrières entièrement raison je
pense qu'on peut dans les enseignements
à tirer dans les enseignements à tirer
c'est ça c'est une nouvelle éducation à
la santé une nouvelle hygiène et je suis
capable je pense qu'on sera capable de
faire reculer l'épidémie de
gastro-entérite d'autres contaminations
et c'est aussi dans la question des
contaminations avec la question du port
du masque et des gestes barrières
je ne sais pas quand nous allons
reprendre nos habitudes de nous serrer
la main et nous embrasser j'ai peur par
contre sur certains domaines qu'on y
perde en convivialité
prenez mais par contre se laver les
mains et pas seulement avec du gel hydro
alcoolique mais se laver les mains avec
de l'eau et du savon
aussi quelques très important et au plus
jeune âge je trouve que les jeunes
générations bien intégré ça mais il faut
justement que ça puisque ça puisse
continuer sur la question de la
logistique xav entièrement raison alors
je ne comprends pas pourquoi pardonnez
moi on est allé pour les dotations aux
pharmacies aller chercher une entreprise
privée elle est connue elle est
peut-être compétentes
enfin un thème qui sur leur gps n'avait
pas les bonnes adresses des pharmacies
il ya des gens qui s'affairent dans ce
pays appelle les militaires ça appelle
les gendarmes
et quand on dit c'est à la guerre comme
à la guerre ils s'affairent et j'aurais
vous donner un exemple pour l'opération
dans les hauts de france
un masque pour tout ça dans le
département de la somme les gendarmes
sont allés proposé avec l'accord du
préfet sont allés proposé à
l'association des maires et au conseil
départemental en dix ans la partie
transport de vos masques avec le conseil
régional
on la prend en charge à 100% ils ont été
formidables
sur cette partie de logistique ils ont
été disponibles même les week-ends même
même des jours fériés
j'ai vu l'expérience il venait les
chercher eux mêmes il est ventilé on
avait donc la sécurisation et une
fiabilité exceptionnelle et je leur ai
dit quand j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller les
remercier pour cette opération mais bon
sang il s'affaire ils s'affairent et je
suis intimement convaincu qu'on aurait
confié cette partie logistique dès le
départ on n'aurait pas eu l'épreuve
d'acheminement il ya le problème bien
évidemment de la disponibilité des
masques mais ensuite même quand il y
avait des masques il y avait ce problème
de l'acheminement
ils s'affairent nos militaires et nos
gendarmes s'affairent partout sur le
territoire et ensuite vous pouviez très
bien complétés en zone police notamment
écrit militaire si vous le souhaitiez
mais il y avait effectivement vraiment
de quoi faire et voilà en terme de
logistique
j'ai ils ont un regard de gens qui ne
traverse pas dans les clous et s'est
sérieusement précieux il faut vous
essayez d'avoir une vision à 360 et un
degré c'est-à-dire que vous faites le
tour complète et après vous allez encore
à nouveau sur ce que vous aviez vu au
début
est ce que vous êtes est à regard
différent et puis surtout pratico
pratique les plans qui sont bons sur le
papier faut faire attention ce qu'on n'a
pas des plans de papier et on en reine
arrive aussi à ce que disait bertrand
pancher
la première des choses c'est
l'appropriation politique c'est au
politique
c'est aux politiques de dire voilà sur
des sujets comme seul
on va y mettre les moyens qu'il faut
même en sachant qu'on va y mettre les
moyens qu'il faut mais on va se mettre à
niveau
deuxième aspect il faut pas que ce soit
que l'état il faut qu'il y ait une
sensibilisation citoyenne et notamment
le plus jeune âge prenez notamment ce
qui se passe en cas de séisme au japon
où il ya des attitudes qui sont assez
différentes
on attend peut-être pas tout de l'état
mais l'état est là et notamment sur
l'éducation mais pour le reste
à partir du moment où vous êtes dans une
fonction régalienne c'est aussi à l'état
d'y mettre les moyens et de s'assurer
que tout le monde s'approprie les choses
voyez 2013 à la limite aurait pu
s'entendre si derrière il y avait eu de
la part de l'état le souci d'accompagner
et de vérifier je pense que c'est la
moins bon système que de garder la
maîtrise complet voilà mais en attendant
c'est ça le véritable enjeu
et après il faut faire très attention
aux agences parce que les agences
éloigne la responsabilité du politique
et dilue la responsabilité politique il
faut faire aussi attention à ce qu'il
n'y ait pas trop d' agences et trop de
grandes agences
le big is beautiful comme on dit en en
picard honnêtement c'est pas la
meilleure façon il ya vu un rapport
intéressant qui avait été fait par jean
françois girard mais il y avait aussi
des remarques parce que notamment après
le scandale du médiator on n'avait pas
voulu tout réunir en une seule agence
parce qu'après vous avez du mal à garder
un petit peu cette efficacité et à
pouvoir aller dans nos sens du détail ou
du sur mesure
donc je pense qu'il faut toujours faire
très attention aux agences qui sont
dévorante de crédit dévorante de
personnel tout ça et il faut surtout
chercher ce qui est efficace et avec le
contrôle je lui ai dit tout à l'heure je
pense qu'il faut une nouvelle loi de
sécurité et de programmation en matière
de sécurité sanitaire
j'en suis intimement convaincu je pense
qu'il faut retrouver un eprus
indépendant placé auprès du premier
ministre et il faut un contrôle vigilant
de la part de la représentation
nationale
la part de la représentation nationale
pour pouvoir s'assurer comme on le fait
sur les questions de sécurité comme on
peut le faire sur les questions de
renseignement
sur tous ces aspects et après il faut
aussi se doter à nouveau de la des
grands discours des moyens d'avoir une
véritable souveraineté économique dans
des domaines comme ça mais de façon
assez extensive les masques oui mais pas
seulement les masques
pourquoi pas les tests mais où
les traitements et les médicaments et
donc je pense que ça doit nous mobiliser
parce que on le voit bien
je lui ai dit tout à l'heure il s'agit
pas d'avoir un tableau qui soit trop de
trous sombre où qu'ils soient trop trop
positif je pense que la vérité c'est que
c'est un drame que nous avons surmontés
parce que les français ont fait preuve
d'une résilience extra ordinaire et
extraordinaire et que la question qui va
se poser maintenant c'est que si nous
pensons que tout ceci est derrière nous
et qu'on met du coup dans un cycle qu'on
est tranquille pour dix ou vingt ans
celui qui pensera ça est un inconscient
ça peut se reproduire très vite et je ne
suis même pas dans le contexte d'une
deuxième vague mais encore une fois il
vaut mieux avoir en tête le scénario du
pire est de comprendre aussi que les
décisions ne peuvent pas être entravée
par du court termisme budgétaire et
comptable
le conseil scientifique a évoqué la
probabilité très forte d'une seconde
vague mais il ya naturellement la
question d'autres épisode pandémique
donc si vous aviez des urgences
aujourd'hui à mettre en oeuvre à court
terme
quelle quelle position et puis de façon
plus structurelle quelles réformes de
fond engagées mais bon c'est vous
pourriez peut-être prendre des heures
pour y répondre avant d'avoir même une
stratégie sur la presse et la question
la france aujourd'hui de la france de
l'été la france de l'automne est là la
question c'est les disponibilités en
masquant considérant que le confinement
doit être la solution ultime ultime est
que derrière c'est la disponibilité dans
tous ces matériels dont on a besoin
savez tout ce qui est autour du lit de
réanimation était une chose alors sur le
court terme on l'a intégré mais notre
capacité encore une fois repoussé les
lie à repousser les murs pardon pour
installer des lits de réanimation ça je
pense que c'est le sujet sur lequel le
ministère de la santé doit doit déjà
être mobilisés et avoir les idées très
claires sur ce qui pourrait arriver à la
rentrée donc la disponibilité des
matériels et en premier lieu les masques
et ensuite bien entendu toute cette
partie sur les établissements de santé
et en regardant cette fois ci comment on
mobilise également l'ensemble des
acteurs de santé qui ne sont pas dans
les établissements de santé les
professionnels de santé
libero je le dis on leur doit la
protection mais il aurait même pu
s'engager davantage et l'on souhaitait
et c'est donc bien les intégrer alors
c'est vrai que la violence de cette
crise sa soudaineté ça a rendu les
choses c'est vrai beaucoup plus complexe
mais de bien voir que dans l'ensemble du
système de santé
ils sont des maillons indispensables et
un contour des incontournables donc
quand je parle de protection c'est pour
l'ensemble de la chaîne de santé et puis
aussi un autre aspect c'est que si nous
avions une nouvelle vague c'est que là
il faut intégrer
quels sont les modes de continuité
économique que nous pouvons mettre en
place de façon à ne pas avoir eu comme
aux débuts du confinement mais c'est un
phénomène tellement exceptionnel de
confinement que c'est peut-être
compliqué mais de voir quelles sont les
activités qui peuvent quand même
continuer on a quand même mis quelques
semaines pour que les chantiers sur
bâtiment les travaux publics reprennent
si les protocoles faisait refaire validé
par le ministère est ça aussi ça doit
senti si paix parce que la deuxième
ligne
la deuxième ligne qui est si importante
et à kehl je pense qu'on peut pas se
contenter juste leur dire merci faut
aussi pouvoir les récompenser c'est elle
est aussi indispensable elle nous a
permis d'éviter en plus qu'on ait une
pénurie alimentaire et qu'on ait aussi
des troubles à l'ordre public important
c'est ce plan de continuité qui doit
être adaptée si nous avions à nouveau
une nouvelle vague dès le mois de
septembre
et là encore une fois là je sors
réorganise qui étaient les nôtres quand
nous étions ministre au ministère de la
santé c'est que vous êtes obligés
d'avoir une vision interministériel et
transversale et là vous pouvez être
responsables politiques mais vous avez
intérêt à avoir des gens de terrain qui
vous dit est ministre ou pas vous avez
oublié cet aspect là à l'époque les
premiers qui joue ce rôle c'est
professeur bricaire et jean philippe
derenne mais moi ça m'a été complètement
précieux complètement précieux faut
toujours avoir des gens qui qui traverse
en dehors des clous et qui vous donne
aussi un avis complémentaire toujours
toujours toujours
et puis en la vie publique vous avez
droit d'avoir des convictions mais faut
se méfier les certitudes
voilà pour l'audition de xavier bertrand
vous l'avez entendu le s'est livré à un
véritable réquisitoire dénonçant la
gestion par l'état du stock de masques
il a refusé d'endosser la responsabilité
du changement de doctrine amorcé en 2011
à ce sujet cette audition comme toutes
celles de la commission denquête est à
retrouver sur notre site
lcp point fr